if you want to run a successful business
then you have to promote yourself you
have to let people know what you're all
about and that you exist hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and too many
entrepreneurs have a great product and a
great service and they can really
provide a great help to their customers
in their community around them but
nobody knows they exist if you build it
they will not come you have to let
people know about you otherwise your
entrepreneurial dreams your great
product and service all that help that
you can provide people dies and you're
stuck going to have to get back and get
a job PT Barnum is one of my favorite
entrepreneurs he's a great promoter and
he used to say without promotion
something terrible happens nothing and
it's true this is on you there's nobody
who's going to do it for you you have to
get out there and spread the word you
have to let people know you exist if you
don't you run the risk of having a
shutdown because you couldn't bring in
enough money and even though you might
have a great product or service it dies
because you didn't have the promotional
effort behind it I know it's
uncomfortable it's hard it's pulling out
in your personality you're going to have
to do some things with your business
that stretch your comfort zone and
you'll become a better person and a
better business owner as a result you
have to get uncomfortable every now and
then you have to stretch yourself if you
don't your business will not succeed
you've got to become the best version of
yourself possible and not a shell of
yourself
I hope you apply this to your business
get out there and start promoting
yourself let people know that you exist
because those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below I love seeing those come in and
I'd really love to hear what you have to
think if you want to leave a comment
under the video I always read those if
you have a question feel free to leave
in the comments as well thank you so
much and I'll see you in the next
episode
you
you